[Music]
my
attorney advised me not to be on the
show tonight because the rumor is that
we're going to be indicted shortly
okay having said that this is the same
circuit attorney there are at least
35 of the protesters that torched and
looted downtown st
louis but now she wants to indict me i
didn't shoot anybody
i just held my ground protected my house
and
i'm sitting here on television tonight
instead of dead or putting out the
smoldering embers of my home
absolutely a missouri homeowner says he
and his wife are
expected to be indicted after being
armed during a confrontation with
protesters who broke into their gated
community their gated house
here with reaction is the host of the
dave rubin show a guy named dave rubin
dave good morning to you
good morning guys okay so can you
explain that to us
here's somebody who was in their house
with their family
they heard a disturbance they looked out
they saw these people breaking down
the gate trespassing on private property
they went to get their gun because they
felt that they were
in peril and now they may be in trouble
well brian i don't know that i can
explain it any better than that i mean
this
is seriously seriously dangerous the
mccloskeys did not wake up
that morning with the decision that they
were going to go out there and hunt
people down
they protected their property it was a
private street
a gate was broken into we've been
watching for weeks
probably over a month now of you know
how
businesses being burned down and people
being attacked on the streets
and windows being broken and all sorts
of stuff they did
what is their god-given right which is
protected by the second amendment in the
united states to protect their property
they did not harass anybody they didn't
they certainly didn't shoot anybody
and the idea that they could possibly be
indicted i mean that's a far
bigger indictment of the criminal
justice system
than it is of the mccloskeys they're
american heroes i mean this is this is a
seriously chilling story
that everyone needs to pay attention to
if you can't protect
uh your own property and your family in
a time when we're being told that
they're going to defund the police then
we have a major major problem on our
hands
so dave you brought up the second
amendment and what are the implications
for our right to bear arms as things
like this
develops and especially if it's true
that there is an indictment around the
corner
yeah well look we've been hearing all
sorts of stats that more guns have been
bought in the last couple months than
any time in american history over the
last
several decades i'm i'm actually a
first-time
uh gun owner now just in the last month
um i think people are realizing
that police are doing the best they can
i think
most americans probably 90 plus percent
of americans
believe that 90 plus percent of police
officers are doing a tough job and and
doing a great job most of the time
but because there's this radical left
marxist
movement i mean that is what it is you
know look on the black lives matter
website that's what it says
it is when they say defund the police
they mean defund the police and if we
don't have police to protect us
then you have to be able to protect
yourself and by the way if you have
police to protect you
you still have the right to protect
yourself so
i think i think more people are
realizing that your security is on you
and
in a bizarre sense that is actually good
that is
actually returning to the constitution
the mccloskeys were not trying to hurt
anyone just remember
these are people just like anyone
watching fox and friends this morning
and if a mob showed up outside of your
house as you're watching videos
of stores being burned down and private
property being looted
you would want to protect yourself and
your family too they didn't wake up that
morning with the decision oh we're going
to go out there
and harass people this was on their own
property right good point and
dave let's move on and talk about
another topic and that is the president
of goya foods family-run business
uh came out and appeared with the
president said some nice things about
him and his pro-business attitude
and policies and because of that there
was this huge
global goya pushback boycott
and it's turned into i guess flipped
around now it's coming
up by cot so now we're playing politics
with beans
uh here is mike oppelka on how this all
got started
what's going on here is the
offendenistas as we call them
are trying to make sure that only their
voice is heard
and if you don't agree with them they
want you shut down
so he's a brave man i support this ceo
it looks like love is winning and that's
really what this
is about taking a a negative and turning
it into a positive that works for
the employees of goya and the people who
need food right now so we're trying to
fight anger with love buying the food
give it to food banks dave how do we get
here
the offendenistas i like that one well
how do we get here i mean we've been
dealing with this
people that have been paying attention
to these types of stories on college
campuses and
de-platforming professors and not
letting certain speakers come to campus
and things like that this has been going
on
for quite some time but i think it is
time
that average people decide to cancel
cancel culture so this is a beautiful
thing this is what the market and
capitalism and competition are all about
this is a this is a beautiful
american story because as people are
going in to just
try to take out goya uh it's like people
other people are saying no we're gonna
actually support them
and i hope they come out stronger and it
doesn't matter you know this is the
strange thing where everything's become
so politicized it doesn't matter
whether you buy beans from a company
that the pre that
that the ceo happens to support the
president or doesn't most people don't
want
every facet of our lives to be
politicized so when you turn on espn
it's all politics so you turn on the
cartoon network
and it's all politics and i think the
idea that people are taking more
responsibility in a certain way it's
linked
to the previous story people are taking
personal responsibility to protect
themselves
and i think people are taking personal
responsibility and saying oh i see
someone being brave standing up for what
they believe in
so i want to support them so cancel
cancel culture i mean people
people really have had it and if you
don't cancel it by the way
it will come for you you know your
silence is acquiescing to it it's you're
you're just a frog in a slowly boiling
pot and it usually does not work out
well for the frog
it never does look how political we've
gotten over a can of beans
all right dave rubin thank you very much
for joining us live from
l.a on this tuesday morning my pleasure
guys
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell